you don't call of duty squeeze
aujourd'hui accompagné de qui est pour
nous plus parfait avec c'est que ça
c'est une écran non non c'est non ok
parfait alors on est en écran scindé
je suis besoin moi aussi moi ici à temps
genre mais tu ne connais pas la main de
celle du chevalier du chauffeur tout
c'est sa main sur mon mec mêlée ah bon
alors pour un film épique thor on ne
connaît pas la mab
on est juste en train de brûler on ne
sait pas par où arrivent les ondes je me
dis que tu marches sur l'espèce de
feuilles de tumeurs sont bruts oui bah
oui mais merci je vais m'en doute à
tournon tain c'est bon j'ai trouvé un
abri vient pour acheter purement interne
ya pas un trucage bon on s'en fout des
hommes remake la mecque mais c'est trop
mauvais l'addition en caisse ou sont des
portes mais déjà ce serait bien oui on
est bon alors on va prendre donc c'est
notre deuxième sont bien tous les deux
notre premier était sur la ferme
il en a fait un j'en ai fait mon côté et
que tu n'as make money fait pas trop le
mec mais regard mais tu vas tu m'écoutes
[ __ ] c'est la première manche les
[ __ ] mais ta gueule mais tf1 qui
consomme sous là parce que je me suis
jamais de brûler deux côtés de pt je
fais ce que je devais 4 mai à alain
portes mec mais je ne connais pas et
maintenant il va cherche à jeter une
chanson je veux même endroit derrière
moi non mais moi
assad à mener à tanger le feu au cul
comme des fois j'ai encore les faits au
fait ce mec c'est insupportable on va
changer de mode parce que j'en ai marre
du kram ou alors on a même un truc c'est
pas possible non mec c'est normal
d'attendre oui tu vas l'avait pas des
portes à temps acheter énergie mécanique
mais qui sortent du som kwa thema barret
faut croire à temps peut pas vrai ça
faisait quand ils sont où c'est vrai
j'ai trouvé une fois que je vois une
porte on vient du cancer du foie reste
pourtant des sauveteurs seul symbole
attend au village su dépasser leurs
travaux et d'arles
oui mais c'est trop bien pour les sus on
va t'en reste évasive cut
vas-y ou là parce qu'elle peut te tue
donc mais qu'importe mais là à pau
tellement le temps je te ramène toi
attends attends un make-up abordons
raquette c'est moi monsieur attendant la
fête continue c'est chiant mais asie et
obliger les bourdes comme tous les ans
la prochaine wii
merci bien mais c'est 'qui j'ai pu le
faire je ne connais pas la matte
c'est quoi ça on veut l'ouvrir oblige il
ya une solution
oh my fucking h [ __ ] soleil a pris ce
prix quoi mais qu'il a explosé
normalement c'est quand tu prends la
bombe ça d'après une bombe un truc c'est
la fin de la manche c'est avec tro du
ferme et fortis est ambitieux il fallait
ouvrir et un billard ya un message des
dacquois en masse tôt non mr c'est
l'animation
oui
bonjour bonjour la veille 40 on est dans
nos arrivages religion escudé nous donc
on va continuer il ya quelques mois mais
j'espère une porte je leur fais
attention à moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
si l'on peut prendre une arme et oui
mais parce que c'est bien pourquoi quand
je le tapis ne meurt pas les maires
[ __ ] ok j'ai plus de goya la boîte à
aaa
et là j'aurai plein de trucs mec kuta
bali au bol d'or
là on a attend un tout autre bonne mais
que je le trouve et où je te plais dix
mois avec des maxi bonne adresse si je
l'étude ici flou mais quitter ou justin
tu le dis moi où alice les hôpitaux
alors je vais apporter ta gueule au quai
suffren trigger est le chat de son
milieu elle qui fera 10 4 bon on se
souvient d'ailleurs souligné rezaï avait
atteint je fais tu accroches nike air
max je mène ce que j'ai dit ce que je
n'ai que d une espèce de saccades [ __ ]
il ya 1 1000e match s'emballe royan max
en batterie c'est un tagueur
et voilà pas cool ça ne termine max a
bavé une caisse ou pas je sais pas trop
jeune homme saoul ou plutôt je vous fais
peur tu fais je n'étais deux ans
d'études à la [ __ ] de semer les small
et tué trois chiffres deux lettres
mortes en bois ta merde je dois
économiser prendra ce tour je vais bien
ouais ok alors si j'ai eu un ace 12
je n'ai jamais testé ses coûts parcours
il est maintenant c'est coupa court mais
je crois que c'est les chiens genre de
brûlures au dos et les chiens non
urgentes ont été prévenus il ya un gros
tas décidé de compter au masters
contrepartie j'ai pensé ce qu'il faut
faire bon malgré cette fenêtre can am et
trucks et qui vont monter en plus
oui mais ce qu'on fait avec moi je suis
en bas ils nous ont sauvés et bien sûr
là il est portée reste en bas et moi je
reste en haut et je ne serai pas la
peine est énorme
ce match contre toulouse
et sans nulle part au but 1 1 real one
shot sept armes c j'ai pu de baalbeck
mec je veux les protéger
il ya une espèce de avance un papier
qu'ils veulent et peuvent donc je
voulais que tu es là mais prenons
quelqu'un de plus de 100 foot bonne non
mais elle accueille d'armes set avec
deux balles pendant ce temps j'ai pas vu
faut qu'on économise pour masto faut
qu'on trouve masto après les manches
comme l'internet on n'y a pas un troll
et attends tu pas derniers tuent pas les
derniers elle est là faut qu'on trouve
la dernière où il faut qu'on trouve
mastodonte comme un doute dans la
pauvreté s il a dû conduire juste mais
pas le cas alors c'est juste par balles
et le tue pas alors à tort bien on
attend évidemment je l'avais vu notre
fait attention aux traits de flamme
basto et c'est un truc c'est enfin venue
d'un acte échec que je me suis dit c'est
pas pour améliorer les armes salah
attend au milieu de la lave
ah oui oui oui mais comment tu es censé
faire bien c'est pour revivre les
enfants devraient bel et bien il ya un
truc qui tp un secret à faire il ya mais
que cet immeuble
cette map et hardcore c'est claranet
soho [ __ ] mais je dois des marges très
démarche j'ai trouvé une porsche ou une
porte
tu allais plus d'argent montréal et à
2500 économistes pour mastodonte photo p
blatter vient on peut hélas annoncé
qu'al nrj lance ça se passe [ __ ] mais
qu'elle s'est mis à tourner la tulle a
fâché avec gérer en plus du tout en
france - florence mettais trop cool avec
hull et quel est ton nom alors tu fais
quoi là tu feras sangloter le roi des
gosses mais non pas ça ma [ __ ] mais
qui mérite mais j'ai pas dit guay est la
pire des beats mecs peut aussi [ __ ] tu
vois un crâne un crâne n'y a personne au
tour de tf1 de musique commence à tirer
dessus et j'ai vu que c'était pas un
objet et on peut acheter un truc de
réanimation le sénat news les asus s
attend pour matt au drame en lecture et
en [ __ ] de crâne qui dépasse vas-y
bien j'ai bien servi tués non nous
n'avons plus le choix
des mecs on prend le cas car on comprend
rien la map sérieux on pas content lâche
quelques caisses des zombies tu vois
comme ken le survivant et merci doit-on
redouter que je voudrais vraiment qu'on
trouve mais je tournais qui m'ont par la
groupe regarde je sais je sais mais je
sais mais qu attend comment je sais pas
je sais même plus si cela ne marche pas
je suis mort g maintenir pour prendre
date en battant j'étais un temps d'été
en détresse d'escrimeurs de leur tour du
corps c et d et j'ai assez pour mme
ashton nommée vienne où la vienne tout
haut mais critique vraiment vraiment
qu'on trouve la semaine c'est pas du
tout une bonne claque qui suis ok je
vais jouer au couteau attentes en mai
mais qu'il faut qu il attend mais c'est
quoi ça son cours grâce à ses rivales
faut qu en dernier survivant et qu'on
fasse vraiment genre conçu également la
voilà ma foi je suis d'accord avec vous
pendant là dessus pas là tu passes au
sol mais il en reste
comment tu sais j'ai vu par en bas ah
ouais y en a un
en fait dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
problème il fait quelques problèmes ils
t'aiment pas du tout c'est l'auteur de
support à ce buzz
j'en ai trop marre d'être et il ya même
pas de vote d'un de tes enfants
mexes et juste aucune cottereau son
habitude rouge de tumeurs tu sors pas
tumeur au foie il faut trouver match à
mon avis on au vert bien à mon avis mais
à mon avis on tour nous raconte comment
la ligue quoi à mon ami à mon avis un
monde vit à mon avis un monte monte
monte monte mais que ça sert à rien gala
vous êtes fan des gadgets look at me now
ouais ouais je te manque de trophée map
bateau je saute
l es tu amènes du café 1 2 je fais je
veux si tu es vachement mettre dans la
tête un peu les portes
pourquoi c'est moi si toi tu en as tu me
la note a+ mec je buvais cette [ __ ] de
jeu direct pas avec tes conneries comme
toi et tes conneries mais jacques écoute
moi tu as laser bill va arriver là tu
resterais chez ton mais j adore ce
changement et je vous retrouve demain va
pas là bas je sais gauche fg terroriste
tu vois à l'armée on apprend silence et
bien c'est comme ça c'est quoi ça je
serai pas un petit mastodonte j'ai perdu
7 tonnes pour le trou tu veux tu as a
nazi paul thomas va tomber car je suis
un gros bâtard c'est bien beau mais où
est il
c'est paris et a fait beau l'équipe la
mer donc cacher les collèges faire des
marches des podiums je mens mais ça
c'est fait
le single man on attend mais qui donne
tout projet make my brother sausage est
tu voi le mec qui marche la sueur sur le
feu la regarde moi tu es superbe keller
mais blague mais que je vais conclure
coutume est non puisque tout va en tout
cas une grosse chute des bourses
plongent pas pourquoi mais j'ai rarement
le gall masse tous et le plan à ne pas
faire jouer c'est le truc de merde tu
vois le temps avec moi comme ça depuis
que je suis à temps je veux juste en
occuper mon paquet a tu veux je me
demande de quitter pour ça je mets dans
le jeu de me mettre m'occuper bas à
droite
accor à droite ce trailer suis très
terroir oui j'allais le faire et tu vas
lente au curé là deux fois en bas on me
frappe soudan occupée non m occuper je
te dis non mais non mais là avec moi le
truc tu peux mais occupées allez on y
retourne
on y retourne la vache noire alors à toi
non mais mais mais j'ai plus rien au
batteur d'accord je suis tourné
aujourd'hui champagne ça ou pas bordel
là je peux tu t'es des flots j'ai plus
de base mais j'ai pas toujours eu en
fait tous les spots beaucoup ici et bien
sûr faut courir en bas mon attente
aujourd'hui encore un jusqu'à la lie en
a deux la médaille au cou thomas dans le
sol on s'attend au pire cruauté parfois
deux mecs x 2 tu me tues tu ailles n'est
tout cas ça c'est bon mais que j'ai
assez ja cgv une arme ici
millénium prend la gêne au salon 80
francs
en mai chez nous pour l île du sud ouest
mais à tort chanteur mais ça va pas de
crohn poids de craintes à la giffle
forez fils katherine heigl m'expose à la
gueule tout cas de décote du post bac
mais qui sont tout s'enflamme ce soir ce
troll de l'année en tout sont en flammes
chars mais les caps negues comme ça
lâche j'ai explosé mon dieu c'est trop
lourd non sur voirie kurumada par contre
du coup tu dois l'acheter mastodonte
pourquoi ça ceux qui tuaient main et il
n'a pu nommer le computer alors voilà la
différence de niveau et le trompe avec
le mastering c'est comme tu meures
complétons quand tu es à terre tu là
encore pour voir la différence de niveau
entre le petit moment d'en comprendre ce
que je te dis au peuple indien comme le
mastodonte mais tu là encore compter la
terre c'est con tu meurs complètement
que tu l'as pris non avec des chiens mec
mais qu'ils sont pas contents mais qui
valait bien via l'internet utilise ton à
cette manière on s'en fout à la fin d'un
problème au niveau quand tu tombe à
terre tu meurs ans normal non mais qu on
a le match et on basser mec la tête doan
que ta plume à te retourne pas encore
une pareille à greg beaucoup je suis pas
encore à mon époque
merci tout le monde était branger
deuxième fois que je gagne un grec dans
une vidéo pour rien du tout
parce que la même personne était muni de
mon été à temps c'est le week-end les
mecs je les mastodontes [ __ ] et une
verge de cet homme d'état palmer cas il
serait marqué un bac c marqué à putte un
réel jeu avec ta tête de même planète
mais les white lies
mais exactement le même passionné c'est
pas la tête c'est faux moi je vois la
gueule rien j'ouvre la bouche et en tant
que j'ouvre la bouche
j'ouvre la bouche pour la bouche j'ouvre
la bouche plus jeune j'ai plus le
mastodonte je respire j'ouvre la bouche
mais en fait de celui ci aussi bien au
nom de deuxième vie dans ces corps non
mais que non parce que deuxième but du
coup tu meures grave plus vite mais tu
meurs pas dessus tata de ce thème du
pain make and is big ship selon l'ami
moi je call warrant aux abus dont j'ai
assez d'argent pour moi j'aimerais bien
te prêter si je pouvais mon cher alors
le nom 1700 selon ces armes étaient avec
la tête de one excuse moi ou quoi
je mets juste en 6 cd kungo bon tu peux
venir nous voir aller meurt en fait
c'est quoi une passe dans cette [ __ ]
de fissures ça les met en place des
règles là comme nous en fait c'est bien
beau et chaud c'est bon mec t'as cut
macgé 3350 grâce à mes mecs autour des
caisses je vais prendre chez une cache
tétons des cosmiques à pain blanc attend
givet gbéléban des idées car la wii elle
et des milliers sur le balcon fallait
arrêter la foule a pas vu mais c'est
l'hôtel tombe à terre mais bouffer la
vie n'a absolument aucun sur la relation
j'avais parmi nous voir avec des effets
je vous prie d'accueiller florent mec
benoît la mine en battant le point fort
c'est borloo allez si oui oui et l'élan
reste actuellement au dollar comment je
sais par son mari sauter par la fenêtre
est bonne et je vais vraiment un truc
énorme et banderoles à je peux tu penses
qu'ils veulent sauter on peut et on va
voir on va voir ce que ça donne mais
tout en bas vite fait je suis en bas non
mais attends en bas genre d aulas à la
batteur bruit quand ils passent dans les
feuilles tu vas me voir danser les
flammes tas d'étoilés bancaire les
flammes quand ils passent dans les
failles faisant les feuilletons flammes
et l'eau ligue des champions tu veux que
je te dise on aurait attendu à c'est un
emploi décent sont ceux qu'on leur fait
pas un escroc non mais de toute manière
plan la vidéo s'arrête à la fin de cette
map
on a juste intérêt à vivre you do brasil
oui non peut pas c'est quoi sa pointe
either ça coûte 6000 mec dg 6000 je
l'achète au duel douillet mais toi en
bas là je veux faire ma demande à moi je
veux acheter une autre un bon jeu je
m'en vais à londres
mais comment je me fais ni qu'une porte
de pousser des soupirs lagarde
c'était la meilleure blague joss stone
bon on tente la nuque ou pas je crois
que ton club monte entre la nuque ou pas
d'accord la nuque la bombe nucléaire
tu savais pas ça en gros maintenant il
ya une bombe nucléaire dans une école
que tu peux enlever tous oui et j'en
avais je te jure gros on sait ce qu'on
doit aller jusqu'à la manche 40 est un
baume genre fin si tu actives
tu fais à d'autres mesures spéciales de
la map et nintendo qui tombe ça mais par
contre a fait un truc et je veux sortir
le plus gros mytho sûr nous aiderait à
belmont mouillait je crois peut être que
tu occupais à tuer des zombies de studio
en poche mais tu es mon coeur était
monopolisé dans l'équipage dans les
andes mais je croyais que je suis devenu
comportement ce qui serait contagieux
j'aime bien j'ai peur je 3h20 coup
côté poste et merci au revoir bon juste
mesure où il ya un fort de juste la
personne la vidéo on voit parfois de
quelque chose qui consistait en fait mon
petit peu les phénomènes ce que ça veut
dire le cas ce ne sont pas tous
n'étaient pas sur des voitures
actuellement c'est quoi le marteau sous
le marteau de thor dans un majeur
elle à la blague l'élection papapapa
smith est une pièce c'est fou a fondu
comme pascik une journée idyllique
souplesse à l'éthique
appelle-moi burgos assez bien bien bien
je voulais d'appels fixes tu sais
comment ça se passe dans le mien
attends tient compte des aînés afin
qu'ils me why i'm et chaises
d'abord parce qu'il ya un an et demi au
lieu plus tôt c'est ça fait comment
imputés à chaque fois il ya un espèce de
truc qui voulons dire eh ouais euh ouais
tu as prouvé de l'auto promotion total
d'ailleurs toi jones moi je suis même et
toi t'es black et ensemble confort
norway's ensemble on forme les men in
white juste goethe annuler la dette
grecque
j'ai peur de je ne sais pas quand à
perdre et sectionné au choix porté par
contre avaient mec mais comment le
rappeur troll kéké façon après je prends
un taser je sais pas c'est quoi mais je
le prends parce que c'est pas un truc à
signer ça peut être que s'il ya un max
d'infos
d'après évoqué pas trop changé le regard
de nombreux zombies qu'on a accusé le
mec pour le laser non c'est bien c'est
bien fais ce que je te dis clame atif
l'e3 le mec ou match mais les petites
des blazers je t'aime mais mec mais
question de hockey vas-y je vais prendre
le point sur mech
c'est quoi ça pointé à yzeure attend
6000 à pointer izard je prends mais je
suppose un mec tu mettais et j'ai même
pas vu céder quoi elle d'intervalle à la
musique d'attenté terminé téléphone
l'attend bgc alors je suis content je te
donnerai ce moment est enfin arrivé j'ai
un peu top pour descendre à peut-être
pour décembre tout le monde aime la vie
en quarantaine et c'est super génial ben
ouais pas ces produits continuent à
temps mais dans ce cas les gens qui ne
savent pas boire c'est qu'ils font
l'ombre est reparti window je suis plus
du tout dans la jungle des mecs là c'est
moi qui ai fait start mec j'ai mon
projet mon point alors c'est quoi mec
montre rien du tout avec mes deux
matches soit je comprends pas ce
matériau du tour a été agitée de
courtoisie à temps et a dû avoir un
[ __ ] de bonus qu'ils forment suisse
des goûts des mecs mais qu on s'est
longtemps attend est gros jump et on a
eu un poids dont on avait déjà le foie
de d'avant bardon je croirais c'est pas
ça pas fait x 2 pendant trois secondes
s'arrêter complètement inutile et je
suis dégoûté là à temps mais n'ont pas
forcément un truc la mexa du monde du
jeu fait plus de dégâts ou quoi obliger
passe t il à fait ça ah ouais ouais
alors peut-être mais qu'il a faits
saillants en route c'est de tirer et
essai de que têtu voici un truc qui
change à ces inquiète pourquoi enlever
la manche john mecke regarde non ces
onze mecs regarde pas j'ai un gros
attend les attend mais ça tourne bien
les zones est ici
d'où partent en moi avec un poing
américain mais c'est le one shot kong a
connu déjà à la bactérie je suis au mode
mike tyson un zoom y trouvions mais par
contre je vis ça semble quand même parce
que je vais avoir trop france
j'avoue mexique bah oui je 130 pardon ni
président je sais quoi
non mais pas tous en ligne itunes les
couilles mais comment je me gare mais si
ça fait plus défibrillateur genre
d'incident est si tu veux que tu étais
aussi michael oren koules sa photo son
jugement mais comment je suis trop
heureux sait trop s'il est allé se
trouve ta commande comment je me suis
fait violence était inquiète comme
évident pour ces infos américain et tu
veux qu'ils soient allés sur le bateau
nix amériques chez 3580 plan du coup je
vais prendre qu'au québec
voilà la [ __ ] tu te mets tu te sur
gaffe quoi et là me point leur volant
non merde les chiens les échos elle
quelle boîte à jazz à charles lindbergh
aux laitages mais que chaque puck
bonjour a insisté sur vos fous et coupe
d'allemagne aura été de gauche et de
droite
tu regardes droite et gauche
très chaude on bat en retraite presque
aux tricheurs
on m'a terrifié des prêcheurs vous vers
le ciel et la représsion combattants
arriver tant est qu'on attend jeu pour
american est un chien sérieux de traiter
à temps le prochain attentat est en
cours à la question quel patron m'a pas
beaucoup de jamais à temps c'est vrai
c'est peut-être misumi chien maisons be
non non non j'en avais une mine max ah
si je les prive de jeudi
je kiffe le poing américain l'allégeance
vous faites désormais prenez le direct
c'est juste énorme
c'est un gros plus qu'un jeu voilà il
arrive des fois c'est la bonne chose en
plus mais alors totalement et chaussures
bottes tellement campus de peter hall
gill et roches orient du sport master va
très bien mais quand elle va nous à
défier leurs idées pour info je suis
grand du bas donc si jusque là vous
regarder l'écran du haut va vous pouvez
citer la vidéo est allé dormir je me dis
que je suis je le trouve en suisse
trouve en effet d après ce que peut-être
que quand toi tu va le prendre ce match
comme ça en fait deux ici obligé obligé
des zombies attristé on avait jusqu'à la
manche 16 de sa coccinelle et encore ça
mais du coup mec match n'est point
comment je me vois c'est vrai mais en
fait c'est ça c'est trop entre le
commissaire adou de ouf ça ils vont
quasiment rien là à temps les chemins
des zombies à la gelée déjà l'ingénieur
bon second point mais quatre succès
c'est pas moi j'ai rien fait j'ai tu as
raison mais chez vous ça fait ça au
peuple attend les ombres les ombres les
ombres h peu avant le pont si tu me
laisses pas tard acheter l'aise mais tu
peux la voir la vidéo il est là là
mec tout ça pour un levier on rigole je
suis missions sont sony et wii c'est ce
que je t'ai j attendais du poids
américain seignosse a choisi ses biens
non vendus bien bas c'était épique cette
attaque
elle est franchement à l'étude assis là
je vais le matin le mouvement assure je
vais m en slow motion pour le montage
celui-là il était malade il a écarté
quatre ont fait le fou je vais te
défoncer sur le stimulent la branche 14
mai pour la première fois qu'on fait la
map son dire jusqu'à moi je dis les
choses dans le temps mais pas trop le
chien tombé à l'eau d'heure cash flow
avec un décor d'un coup là well as as tu
encore en vie la mort prochaine je vais
aller voter parce qu'en fait je tire
mieux si ça me saoule fonctionnement
non je n'ai pas de chuter mais quand
c'est génial peinture d'un coup je porte
un coup merde c'est du pur d'un coup
donc gros mais j'ai seule mais complété
par tim holt auteurs ouais c'est bien là
pour véhiculer
derrière federer au concours ok mais que
j'ai pu masto bon heureusement versa ont
super bien j'ai pu mettre un peu
d'argent 25 septembre inclus d'autres
ont surveillé nous aurions surtout aux
autres en fait c'est qu'ils mettent du
temps à trouver quand il y en a trop
basse a annoncé les gros comme sa chose
la salle et on va les appeler les as
garde
home est d'embellir milliards mais je
peux lui en métro mais je vais prendre
ma ce taux - manière j'ai eu 8 339 me
trompe
que puis-je craindre voyager à bas coût
et là c'est pas c'est pas cool du tout
leurs mecs qui contrôle quoi ça marche
plus l'hermine maïs hermine max mais qui
va disparaître va disparaître je peux je
cours je cours je conjugue en jeu quand
je cours je cours encore comme un mec
t'as vu ça ne dispose t ie mais qu on
regarde elle passe dans la voiture à
temps
mais toujours grave encore est à
l'entrée c'est quoi welcome de jus qu'on
pût rsa mais c'est ça qui marche mais tu
m'entends
tant de temps à tout endroit tu marques
d'origine
bordeaux bègles 57 chaud là bas j'ai
vraiment trouvé une stratégie adéquate
de l'opposition mais qu' le but de
matthew boudreau
thual au milieu des rues vont libérer ce
genre bord deux leaders je sais pas ce
qu'ils trouvent directement pour les
arbres tombés mais que je peux je laisse
rien du tout le monde demain c'est un
labeur à la surtout ne panique pas faire
avec leur mettre un coup de l'intérieur
de magma ne prenez pas notre adultes au
maroc et en chine ou non ils sont pas
contents à miles ou pas mais je n'ai pas
à contrôler je dois la casse toi tu vas
tu auras tu as acheté de quatre heures
et je trouve ça je l'avais prévu comme
ça a ajouté six heures c est à dire
qu'il ya un report par terre centriste
est bien mais moi j'en ai jamais de ses
rangs aussi m pourtant je tue lui alors
c'est un contrôle dans ce pauvre
j'approuve vos [ __ ] le mot reste à
quai sa superbe on enchaîne là si tu vas
tu vas tu es lo bachelot d'asie dont le
tueur nain chaîne direct tu prends mon
instinct on enchaîne
les fils [ __ ] elle comptait dans
l'année vieux zombies en flanker points
car ce salon propose qu'on reste ici et
au pire on court comme ça on fait ça et
on fait une touriste retour ouais le
problème c'est que tu es obligé de
repasser par là même chiant mais bien on
attend là et alain vient bien de chiens
non mais les chiens c'est de la merde tu
dis pas ça des bobos paulao sa voix si
sûr j'ai cogné un chef j'avais 21 bat as
tu fais quoi là ça dans ton dos 2-2 bon
sauver la gauche au match a pu mat on
réserve mois restent derrière moi c'est
ce que je fais il faut pas que tu tires
au laser à tes pieds ça te fait mal à
vous eh oui si je veux pas qu'on est au
fond de la salle là-bas [ __ ] je crois
je me sens mieux c'est sûr je push push
pin rouge merde ils arrivent ils
arrivent et le chien qu'on retient
mecque des gaz à grenade
je n'en peux plus de ces méga c'est vous
les schémas sur l'autre j'étais trop tôt
valence afp les chauffeurs à tomber
lundi c'était une décision du second
comme auriga ça c'est pas un hacker this
old joy
mais attends mais qu'on peut rester là
un peu en attendant ils ont tous de
venir ici comme ça pour aller là-bas
tremblé mais tu sais que derrière nous
d'ailleurs ya quatre cinq six ouvertures
barricades
reste qu'elle porte là bas un plafond un
sol une carte [ __ ] de cannes cosquer
ça me gâche refuge pour la burqa c'est
bon non plus à tenter par le manque
d'attention mais ces attentions
ah non mais ceux qui sont pas sortis
c'est le peuple tu m'appelles toi
peut-être montré coolio vraiment trop
con c'est un jeune fille une fois c'est
trop bien colas énergisante moi je
préfère garder mes points cas où je
meurs échange google qui perd ses dents
avec une tombola mastodonte ben tu dois
faire quelques boîtes ou sableux chameau
groggy toujours m
sport seront sur le brevetage femmes
isolées je peux pas le faire avec tpv
c'est donc parfois jetés
dans les graves lui disais moi
j'écoutais je m'étais jamais sauté
attends attends je peux remonter jusqu'à
perdre son latin super mamie je ne
mettais un mec je peux pas c'est vrai
d'années a tenté de soi disant vouloir
un mec pour le mec j'ai tellement tu es
où sa mère d'uniqlo secondes et classez
vous à brommat en cours vers six mois
six mois un court vol
non je fais bien là je bosse bien je
saute dessus jusqu'au propre attends
attends la latence haute saône non mais
pourquoi on panique par ailleurs tonga
mutua c'est bon c'est un jeu et juste
avec une pression at on attend juste la
tête c'est un grès des zombies vous quoi
bien remplir là j'ai envie d'explorer ce
que j'ai ce que je me laisse plutôt un
coup bouge pas on te dit bouge porte
mais elle l'est sinon des coups mais est
en fait un comme tu veux en rompant avec
le laser
par contre là tu l'as tuée à doha de
tirer tu peux pas en faire et on a un
plan et oui des mythes leurs exploits en
faites vous là dessus at on ne déconne
pas mais qui en vaut deux copains mais
carey tard et hadji l'expo j'ai visé
deux jeux d'éveil ses petits-enfants et
explose à l'époque il fut aussi la vie
ce qui marche dans les trous gars de
chez en bas ça fait chier oui mais c'est
le jeu et ses moyens a rejeté de stupeur
ce mois je vais faire des boîtes et je
vais peut-être prendre ça même
je vais faire des boîtes [ __ ] mais oui
je trouve que ce brave est légal et dire
non mais toi + moi je vais prendre
plutôt mal pour rim ait vite si tu meurs
oh oh il fait du buzz alors ça se fait
ça ça c'est vraiment faire le mec alors
d'avis maintenant j'aimerais améliorer
mon affaire comme on fait et j'ai envie
d'aller chercher sur internet j'ai déjà
jean vidal jamais que tu vois dedans oui
j'ai horreur je la mets attends tu la
mets ta tant qu'elles soient prêtes et
sûrs roche
tous ces bons de la mine que vous y
attends attends attends en plus elle est
trop bien booster sa part va pas là-bas
par contre je n'ai plus une thune du
moniteur au mythe très cher donc des
5000 info et regarde les atouts du coup
je te gemalto donc je recharge super
vite et je peux très animé badji tumeur
avec ça si je meurs mais si je meurs on
perd ouvert la nuit
c'est quoi ça [ __ ] j'ai une grosse
arme
j'ai bien aimé sa gueule bon aussi bien
au dessus en fait je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on trouve une clause payeur
moi j'ai pas eu peur
as tu me tues et la zambie casse toi mec
ça m embête beaucoup ce faux contre un
peloton qui me lâche pas la nuit ton
peut se mettre ici j'en qu'une entrée
l'autre entrée mais là c'est dur que
voilà après on enferme et je t'en faire
rester d artois non mec parce que là ça
t'arrive dans le cuba dont on monte bien
et dès qu'on est submergé rao en tant qu
on saute mais en fait l'autre euros
c'est pas le bon flop arrive parcourir
des arbitres par le plafond et par la
porte on surmas par là vous arrive
partout mekhissi des messages d'autres
convenu d'y insérer au pire j'ai regardé
en regarder ils sont refoulés surveille
tiens j'ai vu qu'un chargeur contre non
résident jeux de lettres dès que tu
recharge iv
concentrée au sol mais non la seule boy
qui avait piqué pas les personnes
l'affrontement je suis un fou non je
déconne mourir je crois pas
j'ai compris qu'il fallait maintenant
mais t'inquiète je redis aujourd'hui
du coup les zombies viennent plus sur
moi ils sont passés de ce marché je suis
beaucoup croient mais j'avoue mais qu'en
plus à peine mauvaise technique ce jeune
femme brock james
ils suivent tous comme des connards bien
parce que je suis sincère
bouchard - ch je recharge aux mecs mec
bon monsieur raison commentant la masse
kayak et brouillard addictives et ça
l'apprentissage arrivée passer devant
dans le monde attends attends avec le
croate en attentant changement non non
non non pas moi je veux bien mais bien
vu les retours de loger les chambres des
zéro charges n'ont pourtant il ya un an
je recherche c'est long attendons charge
c'est ainsi le cas leur chargeur fait
trop triste danny watts a tué 80 une
boîte toi si je voulais je sais pas ce
qu'elle peut avoir de bug non mec je
vais booster mon truc mais tu veux garde
le fan non mais je pense que la seule
médaille mais attends attends rien at on
fait cela on fait cela on laissera
rampon récemment les stands reste chaud
de gens franchement tant qu'ex moi je
dis bien vrai je prenais mans 19 c'est
la première fois qu'on fait
sur ce que m'a franchement sachant que
j'ai vu aucune vidéo quoi là dessus bord
alors je connais aucune strates se
trouve ça toujours pas découvert
justement c'est le talon aux mecs mais
qu'attend a tantôt en plus grand soin à
temps mais c'est vrai qu'il était qu aux
basiques est certain point par rod
davies
non mais là vous allez goûter
photo photo mafieux qui revient mais
cela vous comme des connards bike run
run nature
on a plus passionnant on a tué rebondi
qu'on appelait pas
battant la porte avec j'aime pas qu'on
s'expose en bras deuxième bras machin
truc car notre temps pour laisser on m'a
dit ça parce qu'un patron leur patronyme
encore attentats non mortels molex ah
oui
j'attendais vraiment des pâtes fraîches
le mec je vous dis qu'on peut booster
notre deuxième grosse arme voilà ce
qu'on peut être apte à lodja vous aussi
on a vu cet incident en slow motion
voilà alors faire comme ça j'étais là et
tu verras tu m'as tu rates tes pieds sur
b ou sur pas de droit estime en vue de
contribuer qu'est ce que tu désires sans
pour autant rejeter montre après le
prochain film le trou la fin du iv la
panique trop distrait des zombies ruda
milliards d'euros de trop des choses
j'ai peur artois [ __ ] et le trou de la
sécu
le
heureusement qu'il va mettre du sien
mais qu'ils soient claires on a pas des
masses en émoi et moi je recharge
licence à zéro charge de chance
maintenant je recharge la super d'alcool
heure belge tendo superbes couleurs avec
mac mac mac mairiga je suis sûre est je
sur ce qu'on fait c'est la technique
mais mais comment la merde mais il était
à gauche mais comment ils ont des bons
mecs
je dois regarder la gauche non
thermiques j'étais battu l'allemande
cheveux tu vas voir ce qu'ils regardent
mec te fait [ __ ] merci à tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo a bientôt pis le
piège nous regarde